welcome my talk is 37 minutes long I
will try and speed it up slightly to get
us out here for lunch I'm from the East
Coast so my stomach is three hours ahead
and if you have questions it's probably
best if you leave them to the end once
the full pictures were put together so
the purpose of this talk is originally I
set out to do a talk on digital signal
processing and I realized in order to
give that talk people need to understand
what the fourier transform is doing and
that in and of itself became this talk
in another life I worked in a defense
contractor and I found that most of my
colleagues didn't have an understanding
of what the FFT was doing and so
hopefully this will give you that
intuition essentially this is a talk
that I wish I had had when I was an
undergraduate and electrical engineering
fundamentally this talk is the story of
a point in this case a moving point and
this point moves left to right right to
left it exists on one axis in one
dimension and the position of this point
on this x horizontal axis is defined by
the cosine function time moves forward
infinitely the position is constrained
this point however was not content to
move in one dimension no it wanted to
move in two dimensions and so we've
added an independent vertical dimension
to the motion of the point here the
vertical dimension which for various
reasons we call imaginary is defined by
the sine function so again time moves
forward infinitely the position
vertically and horizontally is
constrained and they are independent of
each other
the horizontal dimension the real
dimension and the vertical we call
imaginary it's not really imaginary so
don't be afraid when you see that now
you will notice that these two
independent motions when put together
form a circle sine and a cosine that
together give us circular motion and
when we're talking about circular motion
we also want to talk about speed speed
of rotation as it were and given we have
a circle we know that one revolution
around the circle is the circle
of the circle and that circumference
--is can also be related to the radius
of a circle in fact it's two times pi
times the radius of the circle and if we
talk about angular measurements we can
talk about radians because they all make
nice ratios here and if we talk about
motion we want to talk about distance
and we talk about want to talk about the
time it takes to move that distance and
in this case the standard user unit of
measurement is seconds and it's distance
over seconds which yields us in this
case of a right when we move one
rotation around our circle in one second
it's two times pi times the radius per
seconds now that unit one over seconds
appears almost everywhere so because of
that we like convenience we give it a
new name and the name that we give it is
a Hertz it's a unit of frequency or
motion over time at the bottom left is a
animation that I happen to like quite a
bit I did not do it but it illustrates
the relationship again between your
radius and your circumference now when
we talk about rotation you can also talk
about rotation at different speeds and
to do this I find it helpful that we
think about the hands of a clock the
hands of clock an analogue clock travel
around the face of the circle which is
the fixed distance and it travels around
at different rates we have three hands
an hour a minute and a second hand and
so you can see that pointing out the
obvious the hour hand goes around the
full face of the circle in 24 hours
86,400 seconds and again these three are
in 1 over seconds so up in the upper
right do the division and you get the
frequency of those hands the motion
around the circle how fast are doing
that in Hertz and then off flow here in
the bottom right I am plotting four
different circles for different points
rotating at four different speeds
and you can see that as the frequency
increases the point rotates around the
face of that circle faster I promise
this will make sense eventually so let's
take a pause here and move to our next
piece of the puzzle and that is measured
data we have a time series of measured
data and this data is discrete meaning
its individual values and they're
measured at a fixed interval so the time
period between your measurements is a
fixed known number and for those of us
that write code we're intimately
familiar with this type of arrangement
because you could just shove these
values into an array and you presume
that the incremental time between arrays
measurements are fixed and we call these
samples so our time axis you notice that
it's unlabeled is really just samples
back to back in an ordered fashion and
our vertical axis is the magnitude of
those samples and one bit of nominal
Eicher here is that since we're making
measurements every T sub s seconds again
we find that unit of measure one over
seconds we can invert it and we have the
frequency of our measurements which will
be F sub s now we have our rotating
circles our clock hands as it were and
we have our measured data at a fixed
interval we're going to combine these
two some people might like to think of
this as projecting our data into a new
basis function in reality what we're
doing is are taking our measured data
and we're manipulating the magnitude of
the clock hands as it were so the red
dot represents one sample so each frame
of this animation is a sample and the
magnitude of that red dot which goes in
this case negative 1.5 to 1.5 the
magnitude of that point determines the
length
and of these clocks so you can see as we
go through our measured data the hands
being angular ly rotate at the same
speed where the length changes and in
doing that we come up with interesting
shapes and down here at the bottom these
are three different frequencies so
projecting our measured data onto three
different frequencies
now why don't we do this all at once we
take our whole signal and we wrap it
around this clock face as it were so we
compress all the animations that you
just saw into one image so that each
measured point is progressively mapped
around the face of the clock and the
fixed angular interval that sample rate
and we get this twisted spirograph type
shape and this is done here for one
frequency weave its essence taken our
one dimensional data and we've
transformed it into these two dimensions
this polar plot we also remember that
the polar plot the circle we can still
express in these two independent
dimensions like we talked about in our
first slide and in doing this you have
to answer the question what happened to
time and then answers that time has been
transferred to the position of the
points around the face of the clock
pictorially it looks sorta like this so
again we're taking the same measured
data we're picking a frequency which you
see up top which determines how fast the
points rotate around the circle face and
we are plotting all those points onto
the face of our clock as the frequency
goes up the signal gets stretched
further and further around the shape and
it will start overlapping eventually and
each time step and our original measured
data turns into an angular step on the
plot and if you look at it there are
certain points where this shape looks
much different the center of masses or
would shift to one side or the other of
the graph and then there are certain
points like here for instance where the
average of all the points is very close
to the center of the graph I happen like
it's plot a lot so I just sit here and
watch it actually but these slides will
be online at some point so feel free to
come back we now have a bunch of
measurements that we've transformed into
this new two-dimensional space each of
our points which previous lists existed
on a time timeline now exists as a two
dimensional point we call this point of
vector and we know that we can add
vectors together so in essence we're
going to sum all those points brief for
a vector addition which I'm sure you're
all familiar with but the axes add
independently and points on either side
of an axis and destructively so here's B
vector and a vector added together it's
this tall red vector here C points near
each other
add to be a bigger vector in essence and
another point about vectors is that they
can either be expressed as an X or Y
position or a position a two-dimensional
vector can be expressed as a position on
two independent axes or you can express
it by its length and its angle from the
origin and that will be important later
okay you're going to pay attention to
one slide this would be the slide to pay
attention to we are in the center polar
plot taking our measured data and we're
picking frequencies and we're projecting
that data on to the circle just like we
saw previously we're wrapping our signal
around the face that clock BIM for each
of those frequencies we are summing all
the points together these
two-dimensional points were summing all
the vectors taking an average or center
of mass I guess you could think of it
and that average vector is what you see
in the top right plot all our points
turn to one vector and then in the
bottom right part plot which is what
really you care about the essence of the
Fourier transform as it were which most
people care about is the magnitude of
that vector and you will see that it's
certain frequencies the magnitude of the
vector becomes very large meaning the
points in your data all align
predominantly in one direction on that
graph they all overlap in this frequency
domain and then there are points where
they are more spread out and the vectors
tiny or there's not much energy at that
frequency
so just pause want to highlight once it
repeats again the shape is stretching
out frequency 1 Peaks when all the
points move to one side and then it
starts decreasing again so this is data
for data that I just generated what if
we chose a different signal how would it
look in this case here we are looking at
more randomly generated data in this
case but I added a lot of noise to it
you can you can look at that and you
could say yeah I think there's something
going on it is interval you could sort
of measure by hand the time between the
spiky Peaks and then you can get all
those measurements and average it out
and that'll be one way of sort of
estimating what's going on there or you
could take that fat T of this single
which is sort of like what we're doing
here again taking our measured points
projecting on the clock of this face of
this clock and measuring the length of
the average vector and you will notice
around a frequency of I think to point
to all of the spiky bits the plot will
magically align on one side yielding a
very large magnitude vector right here
and you can see that in our frequency
plot correspondingly we have a large
magnitude that is in essence what the
Fourier transform is doing for most
practical purposes it's projecting your
data into this new domain and measuring
the average magnitude in that domain
now when you look this up in a textbook
we're online you will not see it shown
in such ways part of that you have to
think for Leonard Euler due to sitting
around one day and discovered that he
could express what we talked about
previously a circle a sign in the cosine
but he could express it in a shorthand
notation and that shorthand notation was
b e raised to the power of j 2 square
root of 1 times x it's kind of a cool
derivation but the point is when you see
that notation just think okay we're
talking about circles at this point and
everything that we discussed up to this
point we can mathematically Express this
sort of way up in the top you'll see a
big X that's your frequency power output
and we're making a measurement at every
F sub K which is a given frequency and
that measurement is the sum of all of
our red points which would be in the X
vector times exp times J 2 pi F which
are the circles times a factor that
spreads all the points around the face
of the circle and I should note that the
output here is complex meaning it's a
measurement and two dimensions an x and
a y a real and imaginary axis and you
have a real component and the imaginary
component first is the sum of the
cosines second is some of the signs we
just broke apart what Euler discovered
here and again what we're doing is
taking the average of all the points
wrapping around the circle which is the
point I will be harping on for the whole
talk
so the process of doing this
computationally looks sort of like this
we'll have our measure data we'll pass
it into our Fourier transform FFT as it
is we'll get to it stains we're fast
Fourier transform we pass it into the
magical black box which picks up
frequency arranges all of our measured
points around the circle of that
frequency averages all the points which
yields a length and angle of that vector
average which the skin shoved into our
output array so we pick the next
frequency and iterate over every
frequency we care about in the end of
the day we have an array of measurements
at frequencies when doing this take note
the sample rate does not appear anywhere
in the math it's independent of the math
and we only use it at the end of the day
when you're set out to interpret the
plots you don't owe your work you showed
your boss and they say what am I looking
at you want to normalize your access to
say here are our frequency measurements
in terms of seconds or days or months or
hours secondly a less obvious point
there's no point in measuring
frequencies greater than 1/2 of your
sampling rate that will take a little
bit of work with pen and paper or
drawing circles to convince yourself of
but effectively that means if you're
measuring a signal that you think will
be up to 100 Hertz you must sample it at
at least 200 Hertz and finally each
frequency F sub K is computed by taking
a sum of all the measured points and
mathematically you will often find the
discrete Fourier transform expressed
this way don't be afraid of it you see
the e to the J X you think circles and
you remember this talk and you're not
afraid
and pseudocode the algorithm would look
like this we would take frequencies
specific frequency from a vector we
frequencies we care about we start a
knitter I'd accumulator for our average
point and then we iterate for every
measurement we sum the average of points
by taking our measurement multiplied by
again our circle times our fractional
distance we do that for every
measurement the average point you divide
by the number of measurements if you so
desire and you append it into your
output array and again the output array
is a vector of complex numbers really
what you probably will care about at the
end of the day is taking an absolute
value of that vector now you will note
you look at this that is not very
efficient algorithm it's Oh N squared
and for a very long time it was not
useful to anyone until these two
gentlemen and the 60s I believe it were
I think they're both John's John Cooley
and John Tukey invented and published
the fast Fourier transform algorithm
where they transform this N squared
algorithm into an N log N and suddenly
the face of the modern world changed and
this appears everywhere
modern communication would not happen
without it and it all was based off this
one paper
practically speaking what does the
algorithm return you will find
implementations of this algorithm in
every language you care about numpy has
it which is what I'm basing this off of
you pass in your measured data X or your
time series it's an arranged set of
points from first to last at fixed
intervals and you have to tell it how
many bins you care about
just like with a histogram with your
Fourier transform you need to specify
the bin width which is the actually the
resolution of the measurements you're
making you choose a small number of
bends your you won't have very high
fidelity measurements of specific
frequencies and the algorithm spits out
an array from 0 to the number of bins
you gave it of complex numbers and just
as I mentioned previously you only care
about the first half of it so you can go
ahead and you can dump out the last half
of the array 0 to n over 2
because the transform is symmetric
around 1/2 the sampling rate so in
essence the output of the algorithm at
10 Hertz will be the same at 190 Hertz
200 Hertz as your sampling rate don't
have to remember all that it's in the
slides for you and again the output is
complex so you probably want to take the
absolute value which is what I'm
plotting here
they're sampling at 200 Hertz I will
change that
after I've verified
so giving you get this output zero to n
number of ends the next question is well
okay what the values to the bins
correspond to and here's a code that you
can use FFT is the FFT library and numpy
there's an FFT function you would give
it how many bins in this case 256 you
give it your sample rate 200 Hertz you
put in your signal and your number of
bends it gives you frequency signal you
take the absolute value of it and plot
it and then your x axis labels are
simply 0 up to your sample rate with
increments of the sample rate over the
number of bins seems pedantic to put it
up there there i've had to look that up
many many times the next question you
should be asking is how many bins should
I choose here's a little illustration of
the signal we saw previously and I'm
iterating over the number of bends and
plotting the frequency output so you can
see that the output changes dramatically
based off the number of bins you have
again this is intuitive just like if
you've done a histogram and you start
mucking with the number of bins and get
wildly different outputs your frequency
resolution is your sample rate divided
by the number of bins you have and the
more measurements you have the better
fidelity you can get there's a limit to
that and in practice the number of bins
is usually on the order of the number of
samples you have so if you have a
thousand samples you choose like 1024
bins most of the algorithms are happiest
when you have powers of two bin spacing
and you can see that I believe my signal
I generated has like 500 measurements
and as I write over the bends up until
you get about 200 bins you can't really
see much frequency information here and
then pass 200 or so there's little
variation and the bin spacing is
something that you may have to play with
that's the first practical note a second
practical note is what we call windowing
functions and I tried really hard to
come up with a good intuition for this
and I think I failed so take my word for
it essentially what you're doing is
you're tapering your signal in the
beginning and the ends of your
measurement window discounting early
samples and the very end of the sampling
and generally this windowing function
you'll find a bunch of names they're a
bunch of functions that you multiply
against your data hemming handing
Blackman there's lots of them probably
Hamming is fine for you and I'm
illustrating the process here was a blue
is the number of all the measurements
and the Green is sort of the multiplying
window function so that it tapers the
values at the beginning and the ending
yes how does windowing relate with zero
padding
it would be a similar type of operation
zero padding meaning trying to adjust
the measurements like if you don't have
enough if you have a fixed number of
bends for whatever reason and your
measurements is less than that you need
to add zeros beginning in to make it
match it would be similar and you would
still want to window to make sure you
don't have abrupt transitions in your
data because those abrupt transitions
look like frequency information and your
single jump dramatically that maybe
that's going to show up in your
measurements okay and if you want to see
sort of the effect it has on the output
so the bottom we're looking at a Fourier
transform of our signal and in that
signal there's there's a frequency so I
made the signal by jittering a sine wave
at like 50 Hertz and a sine wave at 90
Hertz and then I added noise so when you
in a perfect world if I took the Fourier
transform I would see a spike at 50 and
a spike it 90 80 whatever went in to
generate the signal but because I have a
finite number of samples and because I
have a finite number of Bin's I get
noise there's a noise floor here and
then I have the peaks there as I apply
my windowing function you see that the
fidelity between the two increases so I
like former boss said this is proof by
MATLAB Python is aware in this case that
was the second practical note third
practical note is if you're dealing with
a time series of data it's coming in
over time so like a streaming algorithm
you will want to overlap you will choose
Windows of data to operate on and you
want to overlap those windows and that's
a direct result of your windowing
function that if you're tapering your
signal at the end you want to next time
sort of overlap that and include that
data end because it may be that you're
there's some anomalous event that
happens at the beginning or the end of
your data that you still want to capture
practically speaking a 50% overlap is
generally done so you would say this is
our streaming measurement we'd streaming
samples compute the FFT then sort of
line back the clock take the last 50 and
then go forward another 50 take the FFT
overlapping window and we were almost
done so I wanted to give you a practical
application the most obvious practical
application and this is audio data
because we can see it and hear it and
that works well for demonstrations so
let's see if you can hear this we don't
have audio let's try this
is it me plucking strings on a guitar
you get the picture so in doing that I
have measured data I'm sampling it from
my sound card and I'm sampling it at
fixed rates like 44 kilohertz and I have
a big array of measurements over time
and I want to say what's the frequency
information in that so I can tell if my
guitar is tuned for instance one way of
doing that is to plot a spectrogram and
the spectrogram is every row is an FFT
on a window of data and the color
corresponds to the power at the various
frequency bends and time goes down so
each slice is an FFT over a tiny little
window of my data and at the beginning
there is no sound
there's noise like the sound of my
computer fan running and then I plucked
the first string on the guitar and you
see power jumps up at bhim 15 or so and
you'll see there's power also at
multiples of that fundamental frequency
those are the harmonics of the
instrument what makes a guitar sound
like a guitar so it was a violin you'd
see different powers at different
harmonics or a mandolin and so I pluck
the string there's time I pluck it again
and again and again and then finally at
time 70 I pluck a different string and
you can see the power shifts up because
I chose a higher frequency string and
the low frequency string is still
vibrating so you can still see its
energy over time if any of you done a
cackle competition there was one
identifying whale sounds you measure the
whales the contest was won by taking
spectrograms of the whale calls and
doing template matching against these
images as it were
final notes when you look at frequency
output plots Fourier transform FFT plots
most of the time the y-axis the
magnitude access will be logarithmic so
each tick is ten times higher than the
next so don't be confused if your look
weird you might want to do log scale
secondly the inverse Fourier transform
operated just like the form of the
regular FFT so that means you can take
time series data transfer them into the
frequency dimension or you can take
frequency data and transform it into a
time series that's cool it gives it an
intervening step you can manipulate the
frequency and then transform your data
back and that's the basis of digital
filtering you take time series data in
compute the Fourier transform chop out
the frequencies you don't want and then
we transform back in the time domain and
now you have a filter signal thirdly
often you'll get better results if you
subtract the signal average before
computing the FFT and in summary just
like I said before all that's happening
is your measured data as a map to this
basis function which is circles clocks
moving at fixed rates and you're taking
the two-dimensional average of all those
points on that circle face the output
the vector magnitude corresponds to the
signal power at that frequency and the
fast Fourier transform is the algorithm
you would use to compute this and
finally just to say at a different way
the FFT gives you a vector of signal
averages at various frequencies here's a
slide of my cool ideas I thought out
that you could use we won't talk through
these because I won't lunch they'll be
in the slides but I will mention season
1 episode 5 of MacGyver has the bad guy
had a safe that you activated with tones
so like you have a keypad and got BBB
and of course MacGyver is listening and
then he pours out wine glasses and he
breaks a guy's safe it's the gold bars
and has a line
whose is classy so in conclusion here
some helpful resources these top three
links will give you different pictures
of this and finally I'm totally happy to
answer questions at Gala mine on Twitter
you can go to my website I think this
talk is on YouTube or will be on YouTube
I'm answer these questions there and
finally I started a little project but
I'm open to pull requests that would
build like a time series filtering API
so you could post your data to it it
would be a filter and then post it back
to you so signal feel calm thanks for
your time enjoy your lunch